well i would say that in general terms
I'm in the business of really creating
intellectual capital or creating ideas
for looking at a different way at very
large messy complicated problems all of
which have something to do with
competition and economic value and and
really delivering value in terms of
organizations working so it you know
turrets I started out it with a fairly
focused although very complicated
question which is you know what makes
some industries prospering on others and
then later what makes some companies
prosper and not others but ultimately
that that core set of ideas and
frameworks and ways of thinking gave
rise to work in some very powerfully
connected areas like economic
development and most recently in
healthcare delivery again healthcare
delivery is is a large complex
multi-dimensional problem involves
organizations delivering value who are
competing in some way against other
entities and so that class of problems
is are the ones that I've evolved my
work into looking at and and although I
have a hopeless hopelessly broad
bandwidth in the sense of working a lot
of different fields I work in the
environment I work in social
responsibility philanthropy it all
emanates from that common set of
perspectives and ways of looking at at
organizations doing something to deliver
value
well you know I suspect just just you
know traveling around the world and
talking to people in meeting people that
probably at this moment in history I'd
probably be best known for the notion of
the five forces because it's such a
visible and and and and sort of you have
a clear framework that when when people
encounter it all of a sudden it kind of
totally changes the way they look you
know at industries and markets and and a
lot of students get exposed to it during
their training and therefore it stick at
six with them I think probably the close
second would be the value chain the
notion of how we think about how an
entity actually creates value and think
about the cost of creating that value
and in a systematic way I mean again if
my roots are in economics and and that's
where my doctorate is and in economics
there's a very simple conception of the
firm which is there's a production
function there's labor capital that's
converted into output and and and and
that's fine for many economic
applications but in order to really
understand how think about strategy and
competition and value you need to go
beyond that so I think probably that
then would come the diamond theory for
looking at locations and clusters which
is a close cousin so there's been a
succession of these of these frameworks
and you know I'm not done I'm you know I
keep I keep pounding away at these kind
of problems because what I find is that
today as we as we think about how ideas
develop it certainly in the economic and
managerial domain there's there's a
tendency to reduct reduce to simplify to
to partition to specialize to look at
the piece if you will not the whole and
of course rolling Christensen my my my
beloved mentor you know this was his
sermon almost every day in class that
it's the whole it's the parts are
important it's the whole there's
something unique about the whole and how
you think about the whole and how you
get the parts to fit together and that's
the essence of
creates true success in most situations
in so it's it's that struggle to
understand the whole in these
interrelated domains that that really
motivates me well you know I this is a
horrendous answer for a strategy
professor but i'm working on everything
and i would say that i continue to try
to advance you know all of my major
bodies of work but if you wanted to
identify what would be the really the
dominant intellectual agenda right now
it would be the continuing pursuit of
this kind of body of work on healthcare
delivery and most recently through some
relationships with folks at the Medical
School and elsewhere I've really gotten
interested in problems of global health
delivery in in developing country
settings which again initially look like
a totally different problem than you
know healthcare in the US but the more
deeply I think in the more you look at
that at first principles level you you
see that the problems are very very
similar so the hope is that we can
create a partnership which allows us to
better harness the massive amounts of
resources are now going into fighting
diseases like aids and malaria drug
resistant TB bye-bye really
revolutionising are thinking about how
to deliver care see the the thinking
about health care in general and global
health in particular has been dominated
by the science perspective you know how
can we come up with a better malaria
pill or a way of you know using drugs to
treat TB and and what we've come to
understand is is that the the the
gaining force is actually not the
science it's actually delivering and and
and delivery is complicated you have to
see it as a system you can't just look
at the individual parts of how you do
one therapy here or one therapy there
you have to see the overall delivery
system and and research in global health
has not really been able to take that
perspective just given the scientific
roots of of most of research I mean one
of the very interesting issues in it and
this may be you know whole new subject
we could talk about four hours is is the
nature of intellectual endeavor
and and and even in business and even in
economics we keep trying to make every
problem into a physics problem where
where you're down at the Micro Micro
Micro level and there's little particles
behaving you know on the basis of a few
forces that we can model mathematically
and then simulate and sober what we have
in most important things in the world's
have these complicated human systems
where there's lots of complexity and
multidimensionality and interdependence
and and and we simply heat failing
whenever we don't capture that in our
ways of thinking in our frameworks and
so that that's kind of what i try to do
with with varying success and and and
constantly learning oh gosh there
there's there's there's there's so many
interesting people doing doing
interesting work and I'm very eclectic
in the sense that I think all kinds of
work can actually contribute to our
knowledge of these phenomena I mean you
know in the area of health I think
actually the practitioners are ahead of
the theorists so you know people like
you know Paul Farmer and partners and
health I think are the ones that are on
the frontier of new delivery models
really you don't see it in the academic
writing you know I'm very taken with a
lot of what's happening year around the
Cambridge community I mean the the Broad
Institute and the ability to kind of
kind of Mary science and practice in the
human genome project I get very excited
about that in the economic sphere I
think the growing awareness that people
are not robots and and and their
behavioral phenomena that guide you know
how people make choices in the economy
so the scholars that work on behavioral
finance and and and kind of simulation
of how actors really make choices of
which there are a number here in
cambridgeshire and elsewhere are good so
those are the kind of things that
attract me you know people that are
art of bringing a kind of a fresh new
perspective to a problem that was sort
of received and well-understood would
say that you know I believe that the
sort of frameworks and ideas and ways of
looking at these this series of problems
the most important contribution is that
those ways of thinking have really if
substantially affected and transform
thinking in those respective fields and
and that's ultimately what I I care
about I I'm you know like most of us
here at HBS I'm deeply deeply rooted in
practice I what I really care about is
not so much the publication or the idea
in its own right but but actually the
ability of a practitioner to do better
to to deliver better value the ability
of a government official or another
stakeholder to actually make better
choices in terms of developing the
economy of a particular region it's
really changing the way people think and
and and and seeing that reflected in in
actual practice and that's when I'm I
feel like I've made my biggest
contribution and I feel I feel like you
know that that contribution has has been
meaningful and and again that that cuts
across a variety of different fields but
wherever wherever that happens that's
that's the contribution i think i'm the
proud step
I think as we look at questions like
strategy or or economic development or
you know read restructuring healthcare
delivery or revitalizing inner-city
economies you know through through
different sets of policies I think you
know and this may be this is you know
I'm always a dangerous thing to say but
I think that we are much closer now to
understanding what it is that works so
now the the real critical questions we
often face are given even that even if
we know what works how do we actually
mobilize a community or a set of actors
or policymakers actually do that thing
so again we see this in economic
development all the time you know I can
take it will take you to 10 countries
and we could you know I could literally
in 15 minutes we can identify six or
seven critical policy priorities that
will make an immense difference in the
well-being of the citizens of that
country and yet the stuff doesn't get
done it doesn't get done for a variety
of reasons partly it doesn't get done
because people don't have the right
ideas bad ideas are a huge part of the
problem in this world but it also
doesn't get done because we don't
understand exactly yet how change
processes work how to mobilize those
change processes so it's really the the
thing that keeps me up at night is is
you know how can we get participants in
these in these complex systems where
there's always multiple participants and
they have to sign of agree and work
together to come up with it with a good
outcome how do we get them working
together it's kind of work that Chris
Argyris and others who work on sort of
change processes and constructive
reasoning and how how people can
actually learn and adapt and change
those are the issues I think are really
the compelling issues now it in more and
more aspects of society it's it's not
the what it's it's how do we
well I mean I think there has been a big
divide between those who think about and
those who act I think certainly my my
work and whatever success I've had is
partly because I've been able to break
that divide a little bit and be very
very informed about the phenomena at
great level of tail therefore the
theories and frameworks that I develop
capture complexity rather than abstract
away the complexity I wish more
academics would what would would do that
it would sort of live that bridging
themselves rather than see their role as
solely solely the thinking part and you
know I don't know how to create the
right incentives and values in the
fields to do that because you know right
now the pressures are a little bit the
opposite the pressures are too
specialized to focus on refereed
publications in the Academy and you get
very little credit for going into the
field and and engaging the practitioners
and understanding the phenomenon
firsthand and therefore getting better
insights into how to apply ideas that's
that's that's fairly rare and very hard
to sustain so far now what you find is
that the people who can actually do that
and we'll do that I can often have a
huge impact but perversely I think the
sort of the media incentives that many
scholars feel are really not to make
those investments so it's a real it's a
real challenge this fragmentation of
knowledge and ideas is is again one of
to me one of our compelling issues not
just in academia but but also in society
is home
that's a market failure and you know how
we how we think about solving that
market failure and now you know I sense
a glimmer of change in in some of the
very young people that I encounter now
who are more problem focused than
literature focused or fields focused and
if you if you're really if your real
passion is solving a societal problem or
a puzzle and you can stay ground in that
that helps you you know kind of work
across across boundaries but and I think
if we have a new generation of young
people who who really are passionate
about the problems that they see in the
world and can really have that be there
highest calling I think that would be
very optimistic step forward
you